if there was a seam this week could it
be instability there'll be a flurry of
meetings on the UK EU membership the
NATO sector general pops in to talk
conflicts and they'll be a mini plenary
welcome to be agenda I can't give a
guarantee for outcome of a future
legislation the message from European
Parliament David Cameron couldn't be
clearer it would seem as talks continue
Parliament's Constitutional Affairs
Committee will hold a meeting with the
Commission strategic task force on a UK
referendum on Tuesday there's nothing
like a bit of forward planning and NATO
summit is scheduled for july but that's
not putting off a sector general who'll
be at the Parliament talk strategy on
Tuesday with ongoing conflicts in the
Middle East and North Africa yen
Stoltenberg will put collective defence
top the list of his talking points as he
sits in on a joint foreign affairs and
security and defence committee meeting
on Tuesday the EU I represented for
Foreign Affairs federica mogherini will
also be at the same meeting but a bit
earlier Environment Committee em ups
opposed it but a veto didn't pass go at
the plenary so now what will they say at
a public hearing on diesel car emissions
this black coffee why will the new
proposals improve air quality are they
too lenient on car manufacturers
especially in the wake of the Volkswagen
scandal experts will be invited to
discuss with any Peas on Tuesday an
Africa cloquet what's on at the Brussels
mini plenary on day one one of the big
debates will be on the European semester
can better economic governance take
Europe to economic stability and beyond
a vote on the european network of
employment services follows on thursday
can they be used better to help with a
mobility of workers across the EU and
finally how best to prevent disease in
animals various pieces of legislation
are being merged together in the hope
that they could act as a stopper the use
of antibiotics to treat sick animals
also comes into the scope but apart from
livestock a rare breed even straight
dogs will be given greater protection
watch the debate on Tuesday to find out
more and that's all we have a gender
take care and enjoy the week